gracias doctor y las fuerzas rusas
atacaron ucrania prácticamente desde
todos los puntos cardinales entraron por
belarús por el donbass y también por los
puertos del sur en qué consiste el
asedio usted cree que su avance va de
acuerdo a lo planeado como dijo putin
pues gracias ángela es un placer estar
contigo
pues no exactamente
el plan de putin ha claramente los rusos
están teniendo éxito en el sur del país
tomando este ciudad de puerto que son
porque ellos tienen tienen superioridad
naval en el mar negro pero los los
ataques hacia tiff y kharkiv han sido
mal bastante lento de acuerdo con el
paso que los rusos me buscan y les
gustarían haber obtenido pero a lo que
pasó ahora es realmente grave en
términos de que están atacando como
usted acaba de mencionar a las ciudades
de quivicán y otros
con civil blancos como xavi los civiles
y infraestructura dentro de las ciudades
con el fin de intimidar a el pueblo
civil para que se fueran mire sin
embargo y como usted nos está diciendo
parece que está tomando más tiempo de lo
planeado de esta toma usted cree que
esto se debe al apoyo militar
internacional
no yo creo que de lo que parece fue por
las expectativas de que rusia tenía es
que ellos pensaron que iban a tener
alguna entrada en el país e iban a ir
directamente al active y ver a los que
no iban a tener resistencia por las
fuerzas militares de ucrania no yo creo
que no esperaban tanta resistencia por
parte de la del lado del pueblo civil
entonces hay esos pensamientos de cuidar
del paso que iban a tener no fue
correcto por eso estamos viendo
estos esos problemas logísticas que se
están teniendo
allá especialmente el área norte de
quito
y sin embargo nos quedamos con la
pregunta que será para otra ocasión de
como la artillería ucraniana va a
resistir al segundo ejército más
poderoso del mundo gracias a usted por
estar con nosotros